[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about the importance of position
and how position is what gives birth to
technique instead of the other way
around in Aikido we tend to get really
obsessed about the forms and the reason
for that is probably because I think
people thought the techniques that you
as she was using were somehow really
really special and I think you as she
was said as much as that that's not what
was so special it was the way he
approached stuff that was special in his
ability to understand intent and the way
everything unfolded so his students got
really into forms and and technical
aspects and in lots of ways that's been
great for Aikido but in lots of ways
that's also kind of pinned us into a box
and so we think that doing Aikido is
about doing the technique or doing the
form and that it has to look this
certain way or it's not Aikido
the forms and the techniques are very
important in Aikido and they will teach
us systematically how the system works
but they're not the be-all end-all the
position is significantly more important
than the technique so this week we're
talking about why positions so important
and how position is what facilitates
techniques last supply our last video we
talked about honey and and how hanmi is
an important position and what the
position of hanmi really means and the
techniques that are facilitated by honey
this today we're gonna talk about heat
though and me so the side by side
position and what that means and the
techniques that naturally come out of
heat doe and me so I'm gonna get Josh
over here and we're gonna go to work for
you guys Josh all right so last video we
talked about a hug me and what hyung is
and honey is a natural byproduct of be
trying to get off line I don't want to
be squared up in front of this guy so in
fact that's the last thing in Aikido
want is to be squared up within distance
to this guy so if he has managed to
break the distance remember I'm always
trying to make distance distance
distance but he's fast or he's got me in
a corner or whatever the next thing I'm
trying to do is gain position and while
I'm doing that I probably suppressing or
striking so one of those two things he's
gonna keep his hands from hitting me or
be actively hitting him myself as I'm
coming off the first position off
is hug me and hug me just means half
body position so I'm starting to get to
one half of his body whereas here I'm
squared up with them but the first time
I start to move over here now I'm
starting to move to half of his body and
then half his body will be all the way
until I get side by side with him it's
if we stand up here side by side so all
the way till I get here and this is what
we call Keith though I mean there's
three variations he throw me this is I
heat though minx or facing the same
direction it could be choukaku he throw
me so at a 90 degree to him or if I
turned around that would be
Yakub heat though I mean so I'm just
facing the opposite direction so those
kind of things could naturally rise
because of all kinds of stuff in Aikido
we look at this variation a lot because
the idea is I'm generally going to be
using my eating me tank on my two-step
to get myself to this position if I'm
getting if things are turning bad for me
right so I'm trying to turn into that so
meaning that you know if we're here and
he was coming to my back I'm gonna use
my eating meat in Khan to try and push
into this Keith ome position so I'm
really using that's why we 2 steps so
important because it pushes us into this
side-by-side position right here okay
now in this side-by-side position Josh
is probably already coming in here and
that's what I don't want rice is coming
back in there to attack me so what am I
gonna do first line of option is I'm
probably gonna strike so as this guy's
coming into there I'm gonna hit him now
look if that works really well if I just
hit him and he was done for great if I
hit him and knocked him back but he
still will on balance I can step through
this and we get a cookie nuggets that
nudge him a little further away from me
koke nage comes up okay what happens if
he blocks his face so if we come here
and he blocks his face with that we can
show you with either hand but it comes
up here in a good boom and that's the
natural hand to come up then what's
gonna happen is we get iki oh and that
whole set we talked some last time what
happens if he brings up this inside hand
brings up the sands hainan that's fine
we're gonna go in here and in some kind
of arm side control right so meaning
that I'm gonna use this arm to keep him
from getting here and start using this
arm to slide back into the EDMA position
which is what I really want to be I'd
like to be in that position but it's
gonna be hard for me because understand
every time it's not going to be as
simple as we get here and I step here
because when we can here he's pushing
this way so when I step here you see
he's no longer there I don't have you be
me in fact I just lost
position his be look at this we're now
in the hanmi position so I lost my heap
though of me which was good and had to
go to an eating me so a lot of times I'm
not just gonna be able to simply slide
back there the forms make us think all
just gonna slide back there so my first
set of actions is to hit him here like
this bangin would come generally what
he's gonna do is block with that outside
handle like that and that's the easy way
to do it and the reason for that is
because his body's pivoting in this way
so he's coming in like that so if I hit
him right here what's he gonna do he's
gonna bring up that hand thing he's
probably gonna protect himself like that
that leads us out into all of our
shomenuchi stuff it's the natural
positions from that okay now what
happens if I can't get that so he's
pushing passage so let's say comes in
here I push I hit him and he keeps
pushing in he's pushing and pushing and
pushing it and I can't stop that I'm
going to have to triangle out of that so
as we go here boom I'll come into this
position and now I've lost my ideal
position so I lost my key throw me but
at least I came back into a handi which
keeps him from overcoming me because as
we're in this side-by-side position like
this for here side by side as he pushes
in I'm trying to stop him he's pushing
pushing pushing into that right i I'm
gonna lose this because he's gonna come
in and overtake me right there no good
so when he does that I have to push back
here to this side by side right so I'm
getting back into that hanmi position so
the techniques we have an Aikido are
facilitated because we're trying to keep
the position so if I'm using EQ or
chiton nage or any one of these
positions the reason I'm doing that is
because I'm trying to keep the position
that I have I'm not going to a position
so I can do a technique to him doing a
technique the m's asinine right this
guy's stronger and better and faster and
more skills to trying to do something to
him is almost never going to work out
the reason I have those techniques is
because I managed to get a superior
position and I'm just trying to keep
that spirit position so I can read
distance and get out of there I'm
Christopher Highness Aikido Fresno
thanks for watching
[Music]